far cry 6 is a whole lot of far cry with
a ton of gameplay mechanics from the
series combined with the usual hilarious
mayhem you'd expect there are so many
systems at play here like light base
building the rpg-ish mechanics of guns
gear with stats crafting it can get a
bit overwhelming at first but we've got
your back in this video we're going to
tell you the most important things to
focus on first because you can choose to
dig into or even ignore many of these
things later on if you love far cry like
we do with all of its insanity and
plenty of flaws hit that subscribe
button and give us the old thumbs up
let's get to it let's start with the
things that go bang in the night and
also the day and pretty much all other
times in far cry
parkour 6 treats weapons in an rpg ish
fashion they have a ton of variables
special abilities mod slots and it's
pretty critical you know what to do with
them at first because they're very hit
and miss pun intended you can pick up an
amazing looking sniper rifle and
discover it's really just good at
alerting enemies and mildly irritating
them then the next minute you can pick
up a bland looking gun and build an
unstoppable killing machine that punches
way above your level
and to just put that in context enemy
and zone levels do really matter in this
game at least at first so here's how you
get around that there are two main types
of weapons you'll run across in the game
regular and unique and there are pros
and cons to each your first instinct
will be to run off and collect all the
unique guns the ones that come in these
nifty gator cases some of these weapons
are extremely powerful but they are what
they are you're stuck with the mods that
come with them and some just do not
perform then there are the regular
weapons that you pick up through the
game and they can be customized and
modded at will many of these start off
weak but with a few tweaks can become
incredibly powerful
at the start of the game focus on
building a suppressed sniper rifle with
armor-piercing rounds a good sniper
rifle will carry you through huge
portions of this world some enemies will
be absolute bullet sponges to rifles and
lmgs but one well-placed armor-piercing
round will zip right through their
helmet and end the fight before it
begins there are a number of ammo types
in the early game armor-piercing rounds
feel like it just trumps them all after
that focus your energy on weapons that
knock down enemies or apply status
effects like burning that means enemies
won't fight back while being on the
ground or you know running around on
fire plus it's just so satisfying on the
first island the humidor shotgun is
fantastic and can be found right here
finally don't stress too much about the
level of a weapon it seems to matter a
lot less than the mods you put on it
alright so let's talk about supremos and
wrestle their weapons but i'm the
ultimate badass with ultimate weapons
you say not necessarily
the supremos and wrestle their weapons
that you have access to early on aren't
automatically better than weapons you
find on the ground with supremos the
super backpacks in the game we'd suggest
you stick with the exterminator door for
quite a while the main reason is that as
the game advances you'll start to run
into helicopters and boy are they hard
to take down without this backpack as of
right now we haven't been able to snipe
chopper pilots and the helicopters
themselves can soak up huge amounts of
damage like multiple rpg hits and
dynamite the exterminador backpack is
the one thing that can reliably take
care of them a lot of the other ones you
get later are nifty but it's hard to
beat a good screen clear
i should keep looking
seriously though helicopters are a
problem even later level resolver
weapons like the pyrotechno without its
he tiki mod has a hard time taking down
helicopters but in a pinch when all else
fails go find a mounted weapon
and speaking of wrestle their weapons
are unique home brew arms and they're a
lot of fun but also don't necessarily
open up gameplay or tactics you couldn't
get from a good weapon build la
clavadora which fires a huge spike for
example is very satisfying but it has a
slow reload and low ammo capacity that
makes it less effective than a good
sniper rifle or even this massively
powerful computer shotgun
now can you upgrade them to make them
more fun yeah this game is far cry as
hell
so when it comes to stealth slow is fast
for a big portion of far cry 6 stealth
is the way to go because i'll keep
saying this enemy levels matter i tried
to yellow the original preview event and
had a miserable time getting killed by
higher level enemies i'm not even
someone who usually likes stealth but
taking down enemy bases checkpoints or
even doing main missions using sneaky
tactics will make your life a lot easier
and more enjoyable the game presents you
with a bunch of enemy types and
different ammo to combat each type but
honestly just sneaking up and putting a
knife in someone's back is the most
effective way to go as usual focus on
alarms and enemies that can call in
reinforcements first
now while you're taking down bases you
will have amigos with you that's your
pets in this game and they become more
powerful with training your first amigo
guapo has some abilities you should know
about and with some training can become
even tankier stick with guapo for a
while and really invest in this reptile
as a matter of fact you will spend huge
portions of this game sticking with
individual pets guapo can revive himself
in combat and regenerate health and as
counter-intuitive as this is you need
guapo to die a lot to get stronger to
level him up find a good road crossing
cause some chaos send in guapo and just
sit back and let him die and revive
himself and die a whole bunch poor fella
needs to learn how to stand on his own
four feet so don't get involved after
maybe 10 or 15 minutes you'll have
leveled that first ability and he
regenerates health during combat now
after guapo have tried a few other
amigos but it's hard to beat a murder
crocodile
nice boy
so when you get to base building there's
a lot of things you can do at a base
maybe too many my personal
recommendation focus on building things
that increase mobility because this
world is massive and you're going to be
doing a lot of running many of the
sections in far cry require huge
traversals some of them can be tackled
with vehicles and horses but plenty
can't i initially purchased the hideout
network to open up the wingsuit which is
a must for escaping bad situations and
getting to objectives quickly the
wingsuit can operate very close to the
ground and let you go far then i
purchased the banditos barrack to open
up a shop that lets you buy things like
parkour kicks that increase your
movement speed and the parkour strap
that significantly increases your run
speed with your weapon put away at
higher levels you can buy shoes that
increase your crouch speed you see where
this is going other than that you can
engage with or mostly ignore the other
things at your base as you like you
might not even notice some of the other
things here from other far cry games
such as special operations and bandit
operations there's some additional
rewards and xp you can get out of these
but they're very optional alright so now
let's talk about side missions because
they're more worth it far cry 100 does
that ubisoft thing where you're on your
way to a mission and 10 other
opportunities pop up to distract you the
difference with far cry 6 is that a lot
of these missions give you gear with
stat bonuses that can truly help your
speed ability to not be on fire
tankiness and amount of money you can
make things like that the gear itself
doesn't have levels but it can open up
different play styles i'm honestly
impressed with the number of creative
options gear can give you and if you
want to see what you look like with all
this different stuff on just go to any
base to see yourself in third person i
fully credit gear and a good sniper
rifle with allowing me to plow through a
level 9 zone when i was level 5. for
context on the first island it was
pretty rough trying to tackle a level 5
zone at level 3. so yeah gear matters
speaking of leveling it goes very slow
in this game and you can find yourself
gated out of certain areas unless you
play it smart with your build that being
said doing a host of side missions
treasure hunts clearing checkpoints
taking bases or hunting animals can
really help you level up more quickly
but if you've played ubisoft games
before you know how this works
then let's talk about upgrades and
resources there's a lot of systems at
play here in far cry 6 and a lot of
different types of things you need to
level your weapons special abilities
bases mod slots wrestle their weapons
etc they don't all make conceptual sense
for example it turned out industrial
circuits that i couldn't find for the
life of me to level up the pyrotechnic
came from trading meat if you get stuck
like i did and you can't sort out how to
get a resource head on over to this
nifty inventory tab for a full breakdown
some other little tips you can do are
remember to touch vehicles after they
blow up for scraps or even go buy the
scrounger gear from the banditos barrack
that lets you auto pick up resources
while driving by in a car
these tips should help you through a
good portion of far cry 6. the world is
massive and we're still exploring it so
tell us about your builds easter eggs
you found or anything else important
that we miss
seriously there's a lot in this game
also make sure to head on over to
gamespot's youtube page for our full
review and other guides thanks for
watching definitely feeling it
danny did you hear that
[Music]
you